one of pakistan's most famous actors
myra khan has been appointed as the new
ambassador for the british asian trust
supporting its work across south asia
mairo is helping support the charities
peace of mind campaign which is raising
awareness about mental health issues and
i'm delighted to say that myra joins me
alive now myra good to see you this
afternoon thank you for joining us here
on sky news
hi how are you doing yeah very good
thank you congratulations on your new
role with the british asian trust
perhaps you can tell us a bit about it
and why you wanted to get involved
thank you so much
i feel i feel honored to be part of it
and to be able to actually take this
forward
um to be honest i i it's been a while
i've been speaking up uh about it i've
been trying in my own little way to
raise awareness i have dealt with mental
health issues myself i have
people very close to me people i've
loved very much in my life
who i've seen go through mental health
issues
not be and and myself i've never been
able to i couldn't recognize those
issues i wasn't able to fully tap into
what was going on
and then there came a time when i
i researched it i got the information i
was able to
accept it and then reach out for help
and i know how it changed my life i know
how it made it better for the people in
my life so i feel very strongly about it
i feel i get emotional talking about it
so i think that way
i'm very very happy to be part of the
british asian trust yeah mental health
is a big conversation in britain right
now we're learning to get comfortable
talking about it but there is a long way
to go particularly when it comes to
resources
what's it like in pakistan do people
openly talk about mental health and is
there the help there for those people
who wish to seek it out
well yes there is but not enough
not enough um
you know at least the stats are that one
out of four people in pakistan are
suffering from mental health issues
um depression anxiety
and now that's that's that's a lot of
people
uh we have a population about
of about 216 billion people
and uh we have 400 psychologists
so we're looking at you know there is a
lopsidedness when you look at the
numbers number of psychologists or
people
there are to help
people suffering with mental health
issues and those who are suffering from
them
and that's why it's very very important
for people like me and others to raise
awareness
so that first there is awareness and
then there is acceptance and then people
can reach out for help it's also
important that we start training people
if not to become therapist but to be
able to support those who are going
through such such issues and are not
able to talk about it like you said um
in pakistan
um and i would say pakistan india
bangladesh it's still actually a taboo
there is stigma attached to it you don't
look at mental illness as an illness you
look at it as a curse
so um so i think that's that's the major
thing that we are constantly fighting
against that we somehow remove the
stigma that is attached to mental health
and the world's a scary place right now
isn't it with international issues and
domestic issues affecting people's
mental health you're speaking to us from
islamabad today and you've had a big
change there you've had a change of
leader shabazz sharif replacing imran
khan perhaps you can talk to us a bit
about how that is affecting life there
because so much focus on the economy in
pakistan at the moment talk to me about
the mood
well firstly i'm i'm i'm sitting in
london talking to you
so i think i've just got
no that that's okay but but i've just
gotten in so i'm fully aware of what's
happening in pakistan
um you know
i i actually do think it's very true
whether it's the politics of a country
um or the the culture of a country
everything obviously affects us right
um there are so many so many people i
was watching a video um where we had
interviewed for the british asian trust
interviewed these kids who were talking
about
young boys young girls um about
instability
and of course with instability comes
you know lack of jobs or lack of
just feeling like what am i going to do
with my life tomorrow really good to
talk to you but we are running out of
time so
so sorry good luck with your new role
thank you
thank you
[Music]